cours de géographie du collège
laverdière aujourd'hui la notion
démographie première question quand on
parle de démographique on fait référence
à la démographie
qu'est ce que la démographie la
démographie c'est une population que
l'on va décrire
en fait c'est la science ou une
discipline qui étudie les populations la
population est l'ensemble des personnes
vivant dans un espace donné
à un moment donné par exemple en 2005 il
y avait huit habitants sur ce territoire
on utilise parfois le terme deux peuples
mais c'est beaucoup plus vague
on utilise donc pas ce terme deux
peuples on va utiliser toujours le terme
de population pour parler d'un ensemble
de personnes
évidemment l'ensemble des populations
humaines prises dans leur globalité
forme l'humanité
lorsque l'on compte une population
c'est-à-dire le nombre de la population
comprend à la fois des personnes qui ont
la nationalité du pays dans lequel ils
se trouvent
il y à des personnes qui ont acquis
cette nationalité parce qu'en fait ils
sont nés dans un autre pays et il y en a
même qui sont nés dans le pays mais qui
n'ont pas la nationalité alors qu'ils
sont bien nés dans ce pays pour comparer
deux territoires du régions ou de pays
on va utiliser la densité de population
la densité de population
c'est en fait le rapport entre le nombre
de personnes qui habitent un territoire
où une zone où un pays est la superficie
la surface de ce pays
vous voyez que dans le la représentation
du coeur du bas il y à densité beaucoup
moins puisqu'il a moins d'habitants pour
une même surface
on va dire que la densité de ce pays est
inférieur à la densité de population de
ce pays là la règle ou calculer la
densité
la formule est toute simple je prends le
nombre d'habitants à un moment donné et
je le divise par la superficie du
territoire sur laquelle ce nombre
d'habitants sont situés c'est à dire
cette population et j'obtiens la densité
de population de ce territoire
la densité de population ça me permet à
un certain moment de vraiment dire quels
sont les espaces les plus peuplés voyez
qu'ici les espaces qui s'ouvrent vert
foncé on densité vous de population
beaucoup plus importante
alors que peut-être ils ont un nombre
d'habitants que d'autres zones mais
étant donné qu des territoires sont plus
petits la densité va être beaucoup plus
grands qui va être une des variables
essentielles que nous allons étudier au
cours de géographie lorsque nous faisons
de la démographie la préparation pour
bien montrer que vous avez compris cette
vidéo et que vous l'avez regardé je vous
propose ici un tableau donc ici imaginez
la séparation ici ce qui est intéressant
c'est que j'ai différents pays le pays a
le pib le pays c'est le pays des vous
avez pour chacun de ces pays
le nombre d'habitants c'est à dire leurs
populations et la troisième colonne
c'est la superficie de ce pays qui est
exprimé en kilomètres carrés
alors la densité de population c'est
souvent nombre d'habitants en kilomètres
carrés non ce que je vais vous demander
c'est de calculer la densité de
population pour le pays dont la lettre
est la même que celle de votre nom moi
je m'appelle drame mais je vais calculer
la densité de population de ce pays là
si vous ne savez pas comment faire
revenez en arrière dans la vidéo et on
vous dira comment faire une fois que
vous l'avez fait vous encoder le
résultat dans le formulaire qui est en
dessous de la vidéo sur ben loger je
reste bien avant et bien entendu à votre
disposition si vous avez des questions
vous pouvez nous contacter par mail
évidemment et je vous souhaite un bon
travail
à bientôt